same thing throws me over the phone is
important so she doctor boys first
things first
jyoti a lot going on in the world right
now I just wanted to kind of check in
I'd love to know where you are who
you're with and how's everything going
good that's really nice to hear um a lot
going on in your life right now if
everybody is so excited about your
special coming out on TLC world's
smallest woman meet Jyoti at 26 years
old and only 24 inches tall Joe team may
be pint-sized but her personality is
super-sized how does it feel to share
your story with the whole world
[Music]
I mean I'm curious what made you want to
decide to do this is it because you feel
there's a lot of misconceptions about
you in your life Jyoti is visiting
America because she loves the lifestyle
here and to hopefully continue her
acting career I have been yours for a
very long time and I love how despite
any differences you are always so
positive and you're you're an
inspiration to so many people I would
love to know what are some of the
biggest challenges
your life and what do you love most
about yourself on TV
most of the ACC games America came
across a mascara I got a me
they're beating me on I said by 50 games
I swear young NFL bear with me for exam
is over here with me me me t amazing
height for beating be nice large across
many undecided quality would be a tight
through humility 1938 delight your
Mexico gazenga
in your special we see you coming to
America visiting America I want to know
what was it like being in America what
did you enjoy the most
and and what was the experience like
push with you laughing Romanian people
[Music]
can I get you a drink or anything
I see you like butterflies yeah well
you're very charming Jyoti so I
understand I am curious what kind of guy
catches your attention we see you doing
a little bit of a flirting in the
special but ultimately you said you're
really just not interested in dating why
is that I am curious though if the right
person came along with the right
intentions and you know the stars
aligned is that something that you would
maybe consider the gamergate for some
people a meeting I want to know why we
can I do me a favor who puts their
family can run away probably sociable
okay well look you are a busy woman
you are acting you are in demand and and
I want to see you in more projects Jyoti
so I'm curious um she's just kind of
starting
the beginning what triggered this desire
to be an actress you know with being an
actress and this new special on TLC I
don't have to tell you you know you're
very famous and the world loves you how
does it feel
do you enjoy being famous like I believe
I can take the cooper-hewitt
to a baby Germany photography making me
very happy
I needed her but he could not be moved
Delita could be needing it the Maharaja
says the girl is a Dalit and untouchable
are you still in touch with any of your
cast mates from American Horror Story
and what does that friendship mean to
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's been the biggest change in your
life Jyoti since really becoming so
recognizable and such a prominent figure
[Music]
they should have spoken to you that way
from the get-go that's just my opinion
because you're a queen
[Music]
look Jyoti I wanna I want to see you at
the Oscars I want to see you achieving
all your dreams with acting but I know
you're super talented and you do many
things so kind of what are your other
interests are there other things that
you do want to pursue maybe outside of
acting maybe soon after your gaze you
know I think you're already doing a
really incredible job of that because
you know you talked about how maybe you
are different but you love yourself for
being different and and I love you for
being different and for celebrating I
just want to know how did you become so
confident and so wise a baby not for me
[Music]